now to troubling new developments out of
north korea today it appears the threat
of more nuclear tests is increasing
again
even as the country deals with a major
covet outbreak now this comes as
president biden heads to asia later
today elizabeth palmer has more on this
story
almost exactly four years ago north
korea blew up its nuclear test tunnels
at punky re rigging it with cbs's ben
tracy was one of the reporters invited
to watch
it was supposed to be a step forward
towards
denuclearization
but now north korea is taking a step
back the reality is that they didn't
destroy the tunnels they just destroyed
the portal analyst joe bermudez says new
satellite pictures show north korea has
been digging a brand new entrance into
an intact old test tunnel apparently
goes pretty far and they could
have a device in place
as soon as the end of the month a device
is a nuclear bomb which unlike the 2018
explosions will be detonated deep
underground
under orders from leader kim jong-un
north korea has been test-firing missile
after missile this year
designed to be nuclear-tipped and some
powerful enough to hit the united states
the calculation is if they've got
nuclear weapons nobody's going to attack
them at least involve the us
correct
how times have changed believe it or not
this is the new york philharmonic
playing in north korea's capital
pyongyang in 2008 back when north korea
seemed open to scaling back its nuclear
program
there was another burst of optimism in
2018 when president trump met kim
jong-un for talks but they collapsed
into a dangerous stalemate
and the mood music from pyongyang is
loud and belligerent
a few days ago kim jong-un announced
north korea has been hit with its first
major covet outbreak
but even a lethal covet outbreak isn't
going to deter kim jong-un from his
nuclear ambitions and as president biden
heads to asia for his first official
visit the u.s has to consider how it's
going to respond for cbs morning's
elizabeth palmer tokyo